taran edgerton is a white boy that i
trust to destroy my bossy what does that
mean oh the bussy [ __ ] fussy [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is the busy oh [ __ ] what's
what's a bussy what is a [ __ ] i mean i
i think i know what it is a good friend
of mine uh actually explained to me what
b-u-s-s-y bussy bushy means and now i
know this is me googling [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
tom holland with toby maguire and andrew
garfield my bussy is shaking
bussy with a b oh the bussy you need to
go to a doctor if your bussy is actually
shaking busy shaking is um we know where
that leads and i'm afraid it may be
shaking in vain taran edgerton is a
white boy that i trust to destroy my
bossy
what does that mean
really
top tees bremen rock can destroy this
busty period i read that a little too
confident okay top tees bremen rock can
this busty that period that ah that's so
cute i think i i really like how you put
period period and period as much as i
want it ben barnes is not doing that
first tweets video
we all saw his reaction to the calm
heeda heedati thing i know what that
must be doing that instagram game so i
cannot imagine him reading the word
[ __ ] fussy [ __ ] i'm not cool enough to
know what bussy means out loud i'd pay
him a thousand dollars if he could do it
and read everything fully well autumn
you owe me 1 000 of your american
dollars because i just read that out
loud without knowing what [ __ ] means i
could be saying anything it sounds rude
but i don't quite know how to react
because i don't know what i'm saying
someone from buzzfeed has just come in
and told me what fussy means and
that's why my face is going red this
[ __ ] right here belongs to user troye
sivan okay fine darren chris is my bussy
whisperer oh that is [ __ ]
that's wonderful i love that
that's hilarious these are things that
that genuinely tickle me we must call
upon the [ __ ] whisperer there's only
one man we must call darren he's the
only bossy whisperer from miles and i go
to the [ __ ] and i just
the fact that manny jacinto can act and
dance is also so damn gorgeous is a
travesty like if i find out he can sing
too i'm throwing this whole bussy at him
what's it buzzy
got it can i sing maybe in the shower
let's yeah i can work on it so that we
can
yeah maybe make that happen somehow
avenge yogia put this [ __ ]
in a sarcophagus
tyler plushie with facial hair makes the
busy go wild
what the [ __ ] is the busy oh [ __ ] butt
i know i'm sorry i was pronouncing it
wrong now i know i want luke bryan to
sing to my [ __ ]
what is a [ __ ] hold on real quick let
me see google this is me googling [ __ ]
[ __ ] as urban dictionary so eloquently
points out is a combination of the words
boy and pu you get it i get it joe
manganiello as deathstroke is what my
busy deserves or [ __ ] actually a good
friend of mine
actually explained to me what b-u-s-s-y
means and now i know i'm guessing this
involves cosplay i'll leave the samurai
sword at home when is the eric andre
bussy fleshlight going up for sale you
know what that's not a bad idea legit me
and my merch guy are always trying to
come up with like outside of the box
ideas like i should get a custom mold of
my booty hole and make a beduci
fleshlight thank you for that idea
that's just creativity right there the
chemist from five stars can have this
[ __ ] all to himself if he wants to say
i thought it was a busty
okay
okay
punch me in my [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] i
will i will knock the [ __ ] out of your
[ __ ] i will
what is a [ __ ] i mean i i think i know
what it is do we have a mannequin i can
perform all these stunts on thank you
for these thirst tweets this was really
fun and i think we have a lot of young
literary talent slightly disturbing
sexual violence high on a lot of these
let's be honest we have been emotionally
scarred by buzzfeed
i kind of love it occasionally arousing
so thank you i'm gonna
go outside and fan myself from all this
sweat i'm so glad that my mom didn't
come to this shoot yeah i'll be praying
for you guys i do not want to see your
google histories you're gonna make me
blush whoever you are
[Music]
you